je vous trouve assez fidèle il n'est pas
très étonnant qu'on fasse une interview
fidélité absolue à quel groupe de rock
avez-vous toujours été fidèle mais
zeppelin à quel chanteur avez-vous
toujours été fidèle john lennon il y en
a d'autres
ouais edith piaf aussi une kalthoum dire
oum kalsoum 1 1
c'était un chat entre vous oula lévis
seront au théâtre des champs elysées ou
kalthoum un vrai que ça a été ça a été
une cale sous et puis pour
l'anniversaire de me disant je traînais
dans un petit bar de la richesse voilà
au chat qui pêche chez claire et chet
baker mama a joué de la trompette pour
mon anniversaire comme ça le gosse qui
traînait dans la dans la boîte et c'est
aussi un mets mes grands souvenirs de 1
musique en fête le chat qui pêche était
dirigée par une bonne femme que votre
mère avec connu dans les camps en prison
sa peine ni ricard et qu'on va vers le
chat qui pêche qui l'a la boîte de jazz
moderne après la guerre dans lequel dans
laquelle c'est ce produit des et les
gens comme toi chérie john coltrane
bonne chaire est le père de nenê cherche
absolument à la et chet baker donc à
quelle femme avez-vous toujours été
fidèle
à ma mère bonne réponse à qu'elle
mettrait salagou toujours été fidèle à
ma maîtresse de cm2 hier ça moi j'allais
dire mettra de vue ça sourit voyante à
la maîtresse de cm2 très bref on s'y
sent fort bien à à quelles convictions
religieuses avez-vous toujours été
fidèle il ya quelque chose là haut qui
est de moins en moins prêts de moins en
moins précis mais dont je suis de plus
en plus sûres
ouais à quelle boîte de nuit avec vous
toujours été fidèle j'aurais envie de
dire le marquis alors on club à londres
c'est un soutien un club qui dont je
suis toujours resté fidèle parle par le
coeur en tout cas ce que la première
celle de la première cuit le premier
club où je me suis produit quand je
devais avoir 14 ans il ya là un groupe
qui passait derrière qui était pas très
connue que sa petite dans lequel il y
avait jimmy belge eric clapton et
terrain après c'était yardbirds donc
c'est un truc qui m'a marqué et vous
c'était les deux binz voilà exactement à
quelle drogue avait toujours été fidèle
la douce à quelles pratiques sexuelles
et vous toujours été fidèle et bien lié
à l'intérieur la répression la
masturbation vous plaît cela
celui-ci préfère quand tu es tout seul
quand tu as plus détendu sa défense et
j'ai pas dit que parce que la
masturbation ce ne serait pas seulement
un solitaire a donné comme perdant je te
laisse la fuite et l'image laurent
jean
cette semaine
et
m